foreign
people of the internet sorry for the
delay there I know we're a few minutes
late but one of these fine gentlemen had
to pee which one you'll find out
momentarily it's Clay Travis and Buck
Sexton of the clay Travis and Buck
Sexton show guys we're live streaming
I've got tequila here we were going to
try to I know you wanted the Bud Light
you wanted the bike I feel it suits me
my personality perfectly did you see the
statement that the Bud Light CEO put out
literally like 10 minutes tell me the
statement it is the most Bland I read it
to buck as we were rushing over here it
is the most
we acknowledge that we have screwed up
on an epic level but we're just going to
try to put every buzzword we can think
of into a statement on Friday afternoon
to try to put this thing to bed and I
don't think it's going to work
because I I'm curious on your buck and
I've been talking about this but
there are by the way thank you yeah
cheers we are doing congratulations you
made it to Friday afternoon everybody
It's Five O'Clock there
um
last night which I'm just gonna throw
out there is our preferred you know that
tequila because our boss is the founder
is that right yeah the owner of I heart
that is his tequila were you drinking
the whole thing oh yeah that's what we
had last night I almost want to be like
the guy in Jerry Maguire who's like I'm
sorry little man I can't sign those
cards
Phoenix they had the Hoven at the place
well when you own the company I think
but the waiter came and he was like uh
you know trying to explain the different
flavors and I said yeah you know he owns
the company yeah so just whatever he is
of course
the company so that is a baller move to
own your own tequila company I never had
I I thought I was a tequila Drinker I
never had Hoven before which is a blend
between some and yeah yeah and another
it's almost like the way they Blend
Wines yeah I didn't know that so that
was a new exciting thing
yeah it's pretty badass but so with the
Bud Light thing we were talking we've
been talking about it certainly all week
to me what has kind of opened a lot of
people's eyes is
there are a ton of men who identify as
women that are famous right in the trans
Community yeah there is virtually no one
who is a woman who identifies as a man
and so what I think a lot of people have
started to ask the question of is why is
that and how did it become so
commonplace and acceptable for for
instance a man who identifies as a woman
to be in charge of selling Nike sports
bras which really is insulting to women
in many respects and yet if clay and I
were hired to sell lingerie for example
you know people would say like oh maybe
work out more get a tan or something and
it's like excuse me how about some body
positivity for the radio hosts out here
do you guys find because you're doing a
daily thing like me and every morning
I'm going through the stories and it's
just more this trans BS and I don't care
I truly yeah as an adult with however
you want to live wear whatever you are
right let's see we talk about this
because some of the audience will come
at us with this and what we always say
is you understand
they the left cares about this so much
we're not focusing on this this isn't
you know they say about AOC for example
they say like why does everyone on the
right so give her so much attention
anything else and like I think there's a
she's one member of Congress she's a big
social media footprint but we like to
talk about AOC in general it makes for
good or we were sad The View hasn't said
anything really dumb in like a week we
didn't cover that and we're like excuse
me we haven't said anything we have
needs here we need the view to say
something historically you know
illiterate or absurd
um but you know the left they're passing
these laws we talked about one today
they're passing laws at the state level
that are going to Shield uh Shield is
what they're calling it but effectively
prevent kids from having their parents
notified if they run away from home say
they are transgender and want to have
transgender affirmation in Washington
now they're about to sign it so so if
you're 16 year old your 14 year old runs
away from home obviously having you know
mental health issues and problems to
begin with and says that he or she is
trans the state doesn't notify the
parents psychi so
without equivocation that's absolutely
psychotic what floor you know Florida is
now passing this thing that if you are a
doctor that does this yeah it should be
you're going to lose your medical
license I am completely fine with that
100 I get that thing I get that thing
like I mean it on a personal note if
you're over 18 and you want to wear
whatever you want to wear and and I
suppose over 18 look you want to do
whatever you want to do with your body
like go ahead but that's kind of been
the latest for a long time right the new
stuff yeah is really the new stuff is
the kids the sports competition it's the
they have pushed this into this new
realm right I mean it well it's and it's
really no longer about politeness it
started with sort of the pronoun stuff
and that became fashionable but this has
really been rolled out as a campaign do
you think that because of the the way
now especially with this uh Riley what's
her name uh Riley Gaines Riley game is
doing a phenomenal work incredible stuff
but do you think now it's like so
freaking obvious how evil they've become
yeah
what you what I would hear for a long
time because I saw this is coming right
do you remember and I this we've talked
about this on the show this week but do
you remember when John Mcenroe got
crushed for saying that Serena Williams
would be like the 700th best men's
tennis player which she said herself on
Letterman like a decade probably would
be like the 70 000 years right like
there's a big difference between Elite
tennis players male versus female she
actually went as far to say it was a
different sport together she said male
tennis and females tennis are different
sports so they started arguing that was
the beginning of this that there's not
really very much difference between men
and women when it comes to athletic
performance which is laughably absurd
and then they started saying well it's
not going to be a very big deal why do
you care if a man identifies as a woman
and I think the Leah Thomas situation
and we were actually talking about this
in the car when Leah Thomas will Thomas
decides to become Leah Thomas and wins
an NCAA Championship and Riley gained
swim against uh the Leah Thomas and you
see them standing side by side you've
got like a five foot eight woman which
is a tall woman yeah next to a six foot
three man uh biologically with monster
hands monster feet like these are not
similar sized athletes still has a penis
correct and was able to use the women's
locker room and the women were just
supposed to treat that as if it were
normal yeah that's where it moves sorry
to interrupt but you want to know my my
director Connor his theory on the penis
why he kept the penis he's using it as a
propeller I don't know if that's it well
I've actually argued that the
aerodynamics of this go against him in
that one area I'm just saying I know
about drag a different kind of drag but
like the dragon water good thank you I
did a uh I did a joke and I I deleted it
but I was like when Leah Thomas won the
500 meter I was like celebrates by
twirling penis like a uh like a windmill
like imagine imagine you know like just
gets a little helicopter we do a show
together I love it he still says things
on a regular basis so I'm like oh my God
can we say that and Clay does not care
you realize how stupid Twitter has
become that you had to delete that tweet
but now you can just announce the Tweet
right here yeah I'm disappointed in
myself because sometimes you know like
you're driving in a car and you're like
uh you know celebrates by twirling his
penis like a uh like a helicopter
um and I was like uh you know I'll I'll
delete this just because I don't want to
create a huge stir if I'm about to go to
dinner yeah right like I'm like it's
Friday I'm gonna go to dinner and maybe
to clip this and it'll be a huge stir
but like if you have a penis and you're
in the women's locker room for almost
all of recorded human history you would
be arrested yeah yeah right and now it's
supposed to be celebrated and so I think
to the point here we've moved from let's
be tolerant to we're now going to
exclude women from actually being able
to be involved on the Tweet before
dinner or tweet vacation oh yeah this
happened to Buck so I I was visiting my
now wife then fiance actually no it
wasn't my fiance yeah but I was visiting
her in Asheville North Carolina which
I'd never been to before and you ever
been to Asheville North Carolina I think
it's a fun spot maybe I did a show there
with Jordan ever been in Northampton
Massachusetts no oh okay well I'm trying
to these are very Florida anymore and I
have no records
I was in Fort Lauderdale last week so
but if you took like Berkeley California
Berkeley and you put it in you know the
mountains of the Carolinas essentially
you'd you'd have Asheville and I just I
was like oh man I didn't even I wasn't
even trying to start all day weekend it
was Memorial day week oh no Fourth of
July Fourth of July Fourth of July
weekend and I was I'm always like don't
tweet on vacation don't tweet on
vacation because you know the Swarms of
lunatics come after you and then you
know you're not paying attention to the
beautiful sunset and the meal and
everyone else you're like oh like I'm
gonna crush it you're like you go crazy
I just said there are more I said this
is kind of surprising something like
that there are more people wearing masks
here than in New York City and this is
like summer 20 this is this past this
past summer this past Fourth of July I
was like look I'm a little surprised by
this so they went they went oh man wild
I got my phone out he was the number one
trending subject and I was like what did
he do I was on the beach just hanging
out I'm trying to hang out with my
future in-laws and just be like a cool
guy my phone's getting blown up and
there was the the Charlotte Observer
wrote a news article about it like
right-wing radio host sneers at
Asheville like it went all crazy I'm
sitting there like oh because it's
because it's crazy blue there and they
just they were all last summer they had
masks required in a lot of stores they
had all the clerks and all the stores
all the employees and 95 masks every
single one of them it is 80 degrees
outside the summer of 2022 and they're
all wearing n95 and a lot of them are
double matte anyway so so don't don't
it's like don't drink and drive don't
tweet and vacation because you never
know when something's gonna whenever you
do something you think is just sort of
you can chill out is when actually
everyone comes after you and I'll also
say that that's totally true and I feel
like almost nothing lasts we were
talking about this
um on the show during one of the
commercial breaks Trump got arrested and
had to be arraigned on Tuesday yeah and
I feel like that story is completely
gone a week later it's like nobody even
cares that this had never happened in
the 240 year history of our country do
you think it's crazy how quickly the new
cycle means you ever feel that we're
just basically in like The Show Must Go
On version of democracy at this point
this is like a simulation or something
someone else is watching a show so it's
like you're right we forget it literally
happened a week ago people go crazy for
three days then we're talking about
friends this the other thing and then
they boot the next hearing to December
so it's like oh they're just telling us
season two is coming so so I keep
playing I think we're in a world now
where and and Trump the whole Trump era
made this much more apparent you never
are punished for the wildest
exaggeration as long as it got clicks
and served your team right so there's
nothing you can say that is too crazy as
long as it is within the ideology that
you support you know meaning for you
know people on the left is anti-trump
stuff I mean take examples of this like
there are people who are not only
gainfully employed but after all the
Russia stuff they are more famous
and and you you have you've had guys who
have come out and said that that uh that
the January 6th Riot was worse than 9 11
worse than Pearl Harbor that's the kind
of thing that an insane world people be
like that person should never be on my
show TV no one should listen to them I
think we should do a wellness check on
him and instead they're like oh we need
to make this guy a contributor so what
do you do about those people because you
guys are doing a similar thing on a
daily basis it's me and I'm playing the
clips from The View and yeah stupid
on MSNBC and the Liars on CNN and yes we
do it all every week I can do it you
know they lied about this they lied
about that Matt Owen masks you know like
just everything that they do but they
don't get fired and they don't go away
and they do get promoted and they end up
working at the White House and
everything like should we be ignoring
them at some level like I think it's
it's such a good question and my theory
is the news cycle moves so fast that
there's no Reckoning and and covet is a
perfect example we keep hammering on
this not one Democrat mayor or uh
elected Statewide official lost his or
her job getting everything wrong about
kovid for multiple years Cuomo lost his
job for grabbing some woman across the
belly or the tummy like years ago but
shoving you know elderly people by Fiat
into nursing homes full of covid and
calling for a million ventilators yeah
gets a five million dollar book advance
I mean in some ways that's actually the
most perfect encapsulation like that's
the most like obviously but the idea
that someone voted for Gretchen Whitmer
after she won comfortably yeah but after
she literally told old people do not go
outside and garden you know I sent from
crazy La I sent people seeds in the mail
fans I kid you not to Michigan because
they didn't were they certified non-gmos
stores in Michigan and what you could
buy and there were no consequences and
so this this kind of goes to to larger
context I feel like so many people have
made up their mind that it's almost
impossible to get anything to occur to
get people to change that another we've
been you know there's the stuff where
like we make fun of the view and it's
great fun and they deserve it and you
know the view of those ladies are all
making millions of dollars to be the
it's and they think they're great and
they go to the cocktail parties in the
upper west side and you know that's all
all fair and then other things we talk
about sometimes where there's there's
just a bit of shock and and there's
sadness at how how this is going to play
out right there's and what just happened
in Chicago for example I mean you know
you and I you grew up in New York City
too right you were there in the 90s you
remember if you I was told as a kid
growing up in New York York City by my
school my little catholic school to take
off my jacket and my tie every day so
that it was less likely that I would be
beaten and mugged they would send that
letter that's how common it was this is
a real thing in New York City we had to
have a security guard on the Block where
I went to school because so many kids
had knives pulled out and put up to
their throat and their wallets were
being taken like New York in 1991 Upper
East Side Upper East Upper East Side
which is like the fancy it's a fancy
neighborhood right but you know there
was there are neighborhoods that are
close by that are not as high income
anyway so we've seen what it's like
right that dystopia that anarchy clay
grew up in Nashville it's amazing
Freedom no taxes like everyone's got
everyone's like right everyone's
shotguns and and moonshine he's having a
great time yeah
but here's I told them you only can
dress as Crockett for Miami Vice if
you're gonna come hang out I uh yeah
this this I got crushed for the drink
that I got and I know I'm going to be
getting lit up right now for this shirt
but this is a phenomenal shirt yeah it
is um amazing amazing but but so you
know we see these things that sometimes
have
one of the things I think we've lost in
this and you used to have some of this
on your show um in the earlier days when
I feel like the left would actually come
on and throw down which is really I got
into this business I was a CNN
contributor for a little while and I was
like we're gonna fight right like this
is the with ideas like we're gonna fight
with ideas and it never happens anymore
there's no debates anymore why am I
talking about this one I think it just
makes the media less interesting but two
Chicago the mayor's race what just
happened that's why I was talking about
New York yeah
the highest crime most violent parts of
the city voted the most overwhelmingly
for the guy who is going to make the
city probably even less safe than it was
under Lori Lightfoot has all of the
wrong ideas all the wrong inclinations I
just wish there was someone who could
try to represent that side I I would
actually like to have a real discussion
with them I'd like to have a real like
please God make me understand how you
don't see that more people are going to
be shot in your city in your
neighborhood because of this decision
that is so obviously bad you know I did
I did Patrick Bet David's live podcast
last week
so I was on with Rudy and it was oh yeah
he was talking about that you guys got
into a debate well we got into Trump
DeSantis yeah which I want to talk to
you guys about but he said that talking
about the crime in New York City he said
someone came up to me the other day and
said uh he said what does it feel like
to have your life's work ruined and and
the guy was almost crying as he said it
and then Rudy said something's the
effect of I started tearing up because
his life's work of cleaning up that city
that you grew up in that I remember I
grew up in Long Island but going into
the city where my grandparents lived
before Rudy when it was Dinkins those
years and the end of Koch it was a
freaking disaster and disgusting 2200
murders in 1991 by the way they checked
it they fact checked that on the show
that's the year before Rudy right yeah
well that was pretty Rudy yeah I'm
saying that was the high water mark that
was the worst year in the history of the
city over 2 000 murders right so he said
someone came up to him and said this and
he said it was the first time he really
realized yeah like holy cow that place
is gone well you guys on either side so
I you you're right like I'm I'm
Nashville you know Tennessee born and
raised uh I love it but I think a lot of
people who are watching us listening to
us you are New York guy you love to New
York City yeah like you just said you're
born and raised there you grew up in New
York but then you really liked L.A like
for a long time
La the thing with LA was it collapsed
overnight it was it was not like a slow
Chicago has been like kind of like a
slow thing La was like great and then
covid so I grew up we talked about this
as a show because you know I mean Clay
is a different generation and so I like
asking him about I don't know what it
was like by the way you're younger than
me when you were watching what are you
79. so so when clay was on 76 when he
was watching 82. when he was watching oh
it's a big deal late at night when he
had his smoking jacket on you know he
was like Mr Roper from Three's Company
like that was Clay's Vibe but no I mean
obviously we both were both kids of the
90s we love we love 90. he makes a big
deal about me being a different
generation it's also fun is some people
don't hear the actual age difference
they're just like you need to you need
to stop making fun of Clint for being
old I get occasional email I'm like no
no you don't understand the joke anyway
um what was I even saying about this now
what were we talking about
generationally like the the difference
of you guys made the decision and this
is the big this is what I
you finally said I can't do la yeah you
finally said I can't do New York City
you both now are in Florida and that's
happening in Tennessee that's happening
in Texas I don't think we're going to
see the full impact for a decade but I
think it's fundamental difference
there's no questions are you guys the
whole country for the for the country
can I just on the LA thing and then we
come back to Hopeful for the country
just because for because you lived out
there I actually thought about moving
out there
um like maybe seven seven years ago uh
six seven years ago uh so I spent some
time out there I grew up in the 90s
where to me as a New York City kid I
love New York City LA the beach that was
like the ultimate Promised Land like the
you know all the Hollywood stuff
beautiful women the Surfers I want I
don't even Surf and I watch Point Break
and I'm like I want to be a surfer like
these cool guys you know you're looking
at La thank you I do what I can but you
know you had this this sense that LA and
it really was and what's so interesting
is now people say oh but you know all
this well if it's if liberal governance
is so bad it was it became this
Powerhouse when it was a you know
Republican stronghold really and then
increasingly with a lot of legal
immigration and a lot of you know just
just demographic and other changes in
the state of California it became more
and more left-wing and it takes a while
this is the thing about New York it
takes a while when you take over a place
whether it's a company a home you know a
car when you take control of take
possession of something that's really
nice and fine-tuned and working really
really well it can sometimes take a
while to actually destroy it right to
show that you're not doing you're not a
good caretaker of this and that's what I
feel like with with California now this
notion of that is like the promised land
and you know all of our TV shows Beverly
Hills 90210 you know I was a kid I want
to date all those girls like this is
amazing they watch Pamela Anderson
everybody remembers and now you think of
California and you think of like
communist teachers unions Gavin Newsom
being a psychopath and you know disorder
and decay in the streets and tons of
traffic like it really has changed so
now that you're here and you're still in
Nashville should we care at all about
California at this point I keep thinking
about that a lot I mean Newsom you know
he just infected our state he was yeah a
couple days and he I think I truly think
he is the embodiment of evil like this
guy is bad news everything about him you
know it's a it's a sort of Jordan
Peterson version of it but like what
would ultimate Evil be it would just be
the reverse of the truth and I think
this guy is simply incapable of saying
anything true I think so should we care
about it I think we should care because
but the problem is and I think this is
what Rudy Giuliani is such a good
example of and Buck's right about
Brandon Johnson in Chicago until people
realize that their choices are
destroying their communities nothing is
going to change and I actually think
it's more difficult because he left New
York City you left LA right so it's
already so you're going to make Florida
redder you're and and Tennessee's
getting redder and Texas is getting
better and what you're going to have is
such a massive cultural conflict right
between blue Bluer and red redder and at
some point I think that is going to but
really if you could set up a perfect red
versus blue battle it should be DeSantis
versus uh news yeah and we should like
let's just like a real debate like is
California better than Florida right it
was the response of Gavin Newsom better
during covid than the response of
Florida because this is a great stat
DeSantis won Florida by a higher
percentage than Newsome one California
so I think the nation needs to have that
battle for there to be a true Reckoning
my biggest fear is just there have to be
consequences for wrong decisions in a
political process and right now it seems
like we're in a consequence free
environment where it's at bucks Point
like it really doesn't matter doesn't
matter and I used to say you know on
social media you're trending for some
reason some opinion whatever it used to
be you had to worry you just had to wait
for somebody to do something dumber or
Draw more attention from you yeah now it
feels like it doesn't even matter what
you do 24 hours later we start we wake
up with a brand new slate right it's
something refreshing about that in a
bizarre a little bit managed to get
caught in I like this this like can't
escape the universe but it requires you
repudiating the people who like you for
anything to last you know it's it's
harder now I think also for people to be
canceled than it was because I do think
attention spans have yeah so rapidly now
that that's you know if there's a silver
lining to it I think it's that you have
to do something like really crazy for
people to tend to to you know drop into
all those things whereas there was a
time you know people forget like Brendan
Ike remember that guy who was the
Mozilla Mozilla bucks to the to the Prop
8 in California yeah same time that
Barack Obama is running as a you know
traditional marriage candidate and then
years later they're like yeah you're
toast you're out you're gone I mean that
sort of stuff I actually think was
happening a little more a few years ago
because not because the left hasn't
gotten less crazy I think they're more
crazy but I do think that their ability
to both to olinsky Right freeze the
target focus on the target isolate the
target that's a lot harder for them and
also people realize on the right there's
no apology to her there's no bending
knee there's no hay can you guys just
like let me off this one time it's
extend clear Travis style double Birds
to the camera and say you know this is
how this is how we roll because if you
kneel they just take your head
everyone's seen that I think enough
that's the last thing you did that you
were like oh people really were mad like
I I can't even remember and I'm probably
jinxing myself I can't even remember the
last time anybody even landed a punch on
me over anything it's been years it's
been a while I mean because we've been
mad thinkable you said boobs on CNN and
that's when I did your shows wasn't even
the curse word by the way what is her
name Brianna
so this is the craze this is like see if
you hang out right afterwards this is
where you get The Insider stuff yeah
yeah
that's right Brooke Baldwin is actually
not there anymore one of the coolers he
was like you guys would really get along
on camera with you know Zucker watching
from his little office everything it was
like oh look at all those Pearl
clutching everything else but I'm
telling you if you sat with her now
she'd be like yeah like I probably could
have rolled with that one a little well
what's funny is I was on Headline News
the day before and I said the same thing
and the host laughed right I mean
because it's clearly not a because again
for that's when we first met you yeah
for people who do not know this is like
five years ago I went on uh talking
about Jamel Hill at ESPN and I was
defending her Free Speech right and I
was saying ESPN shouldn't be firing
people for tweets or anything else
that's going on right and so uh out of
uh and then I went on CNN and I said and
I've been saying this on my radio show
for years I only believe in two things
completely the first amendment in boobs
because the heterosexual man neither
have ever let me down right and and uh
it's better than saying what I had found
I'm a First Amendment absolutist because
people get hung up on what does that
even mean yeah and this is a little bit
more funny way a funnier way of saying
that and she just lost her mind and
wanted me to apologize yeah and I just
doubled down there's another guy on and
we were talking about this yesterday uh
it's gone viral on Tick Tock now right
like new generations of kids because
because the apology thing of oh she
immediately tried to get me to apologize
and then it was the number one trending
subject in America right and uh all you
did back then was talk about boobs now
you gotta chop your boobs off together
well that's how crazy things have gotten
so no really are we are we serving back
the trans thing for a second because
there's one thing that I've been saying
to Clay since we started the show
um and and you know I have in a couple
of different you know I I started people
don't remember this now I think it's
kind of funny I started the show Rising
which later became it was with crystal
ball who was an MSNBC and Crystal I
always had a very now something Trump
beautiful relationship yeah beautiful
relationship but no we always got along
and she's actually you know for her
point of view I think I think she's
talented but she's very left-wing I
don't know if you know her at all I mean
she's like she's like Bernie Sanders
left wing right um and now she does that
show with Sagar and then later on I
actually did a podcast with uh with Mark
Lamont Hill who again great guy you know
Mark at all he's like a super fun guy to
hang out with you know really you know
he he's witty he's he's amusing and
everything but also super left-wing
politics but from you know spending time
with them and just sort of hearing also
conversations around them with some of
their colleagues and other people you
get a sense of what the true the true
left position because they'll actually
get heat on the left oh yeah from people
that think that they're not hardcore
enough right or they're not going hard
so I've learned from from years of doing
that with other hosts
um what the real like the maximalist
position is so for example on defund
police it's actually not defund police
as I'm sure you know it's abolish right
abolish police abolish prisons and they
refer to it as an abolition movement not
without obvious connection to you know
the the righteousness of the abolition
movement of slavery so that's what the
hardcore left wants there the hardcore
left the true position of the left on
transgender issues is not you know be
nice to people like don't you know let
people live their life like the stuff
you're saying right like let people be
who they are and do their thing the true
position is that these are a transgender
man who becomes a woman right whatever
is a woman in every sense
indistinguishable in how she should be
not only treated legally but socially in
athletics professionally everything else
it is a woman a hundred percent the same
to the point where and I've actually
posed this to like left this before true
leftists so is a heterosexual male
supposed to be attracted to a trans
female or else they would say that they
would say that's transphobia it is a
woman indistinguishable from you know
the mothers that gave us life a woman
100 that is the the definition of crazy
which is why it's so important to just
not not only not see this ground but to
look at the whole argument and where
this came from and how is that the crazy
part of the left and I actually prefer
to talk about crazy parts of the right
because we can do this all day long so
let's we can shift to that but is that
the crazy part of life that there are
there is basically nobody saying no to
this stuff I mean look there's Bill
Maher who will always vote Democrat no
matter what that's right he's not red
pilled I like him he's become friends
I'm trying with him so hard but I know
at the end even if it's DeSantis and
even if Cali goes back into lockdowns he
will still support 100 it's just how it
is you know I think there's something to
be said if you're a 67 year old worth
100 million dollars you can have a set
of luxury beliefs where it's because
it's not your kids right you know you're
not married you don't have kids blah
blah blah but but there's basically
nobody on the left saying like where is
Bill Clinton where's the Statesman on
the left just being like could we not go
completely go to sports
where is somebody on ESPN yeah yeah who
will just come out right on their
Network clay told me this early on WE
teamed up and I'll go into the sports
things more but just was so funny
because he told me I was like dude how
woke is because you know I come from the
news news commentary background and all
that stuff straight up and he comes from
the sports background and I was like how
woke is sports media and he said more
woke and more ardently left-wing than
journalism like traditional journalism
and I was like clay that's insane and I
it's 100 it's 100 sure he's not a huge
Sports guy but you know but for outkick
there is no one out there that would say
in all think about how crazy this is in
all of sports media that would say men
should compete against men and women
should compete against women and think
about it on ESPN
they have moved from okay we only focus
on sports
two they ran a during I think women's
you know celebration month is now March
or whatever I can't keep up with all the
different months but they ran a Leah
Thomas is a women's Sports Champion one
minute advertisement basically from ESPN
and so I look at this and
there is no one on the air on ESPN that
would go on and say this is wrong yeah
and so to your point to me this is
emblematic of where we are that even
things that are biological realities
there's hardly anyone that would even
make this fight and I look at it and I
say there's a knife fight for the 25
Sports media and then there's out kick
and we win because it's like you're
you're fighting on something that is an
objective farce but I wonder I think
Buck's right I think in three years if
you don't want to bang a chick with a
dick like you're going to be considered
trans
but you know I think I told you this
once I went I grew up in the same town
as Sue Bird
come out with Megan rapino and like
right so she's I think how old she's
probably she's over 40. right so she's
probably about like seven years younger
than me but I would occasionally play
basketball with her at the at the local
parks I asked to park and she was there
you've got an outdoor basketball court
I've seen the footage I need to see it I
got a torn ACL on my knee but I can
still shoot but anyway uh I would play
with her with a couple other guys and
and she would play with all guys and she
she was clearly better than almost
everybody but she could never play in
the NBA that's not misogynist to say
it's not anything else and the fact that
she has now come out on the other side
yeah well she but she was long gone from
yeah but I mean they're basically coming
out out in favor of a racing women's
sports because this is circled back
around to the Riley Gaines angle people
say why do you care well the reality is
because I believe I care for the same
reason that I would I coach 12 year old
little league right I shouldn't be able
to show up with a 16 year old and run
the league right and everybody would
naturally react to that I care because
there are basic rules of allowing
fairness and competition where's the
problem though the reason and then I
know you want to understand this by the
way pbd so it's hard because there's the
presidential Daily Brief oh Big Time
dropping and then there's the pbbd which
is Patrick David right so I get these
they get these uh these switched up by
the way clay threw me under the bus
yesterday with a little old school
reference to my prom date on the pbd you
know what's the problem Junior Prom and
we're not even reclaimed we're not even
we're not even bringing this up right
now we're not this is what happened on
the pbd show because that's all they
want to talk about that I'm like excuse
me don't you want to know more about him
political ideas and instead they're
asking me about my my 16 16 year old
it's possible that you peace
I know it's sad she's I'm in the wrong
tax bracket my friend I had to go I had
to go into the government where was she
really she really she really blew it she
could have been Mrs Buck Sexton instead
you know it is what it is so that was
funny though because I'm on P I'm on pbd
yes yesterday we're talking to Santa's
Trump stuff and he and you know I'm like
trying to you know we're trying to
really have an in-depth conversation but
that's all that I've that's all that
I've heard about so far from people that
watch that so of course I mean that's
I'm sorry for blowing you up in a good
way I mean nobody's gonna be like oh you
went to prom with the vodka I think I
can maybe beat you on it
I know you will know exactly where both
of you were on my prom night OJ my prom
night
no I didn't no I'm just guessing I'm
guessing like my prom night I believe it
was it was either June 19th or June 17th
1994 it was the night of the O.J Simpson
car chase which was also a game six of
the Houston Rockets New York Knicks
that was the Elijah on just got the
Stark shot that missed it then they went
to game seven I remember that so how the
Waldorf Astoria in New York so how did
you become aware that the O.J Chase was
going on on property because because all
of us were trying oh no we were at prom
at the Waldorf but all of us he was game
six of the finals in New York you know
so you're one of these Long Island kids
used to be an interloper in my city with
your like your your Neon Lights under
the car and the whole thing I remember I
know you along here very fancy bridge
and tunnel Squad we were all uh we were
all trying to watch game six yep so kids
were we were all running down to the bar
but they wouldn't let us stay at the bar
but then suddenly the TV's all switched
over yeah yeah yeah and then we were all
freaking out because we we wanted to go
back to game six and the legendary
evening so are we are we still on the
seriousness the the metaphysical reality
of trans
I got a drink I mean look at these cups
I gotta drive so I can't drink too much
I got a drink my girl is buying what is
this class right what is this even this
was just from the store next door
because we didn't have any cups okay
yeah well this is the tequila my girl's
at Target right now she's gonna come and
bring us glasses you're a very
fashionable man that's for sure we know
this right you're a man of some style
and and substance in the fashion realm
thank you we had a woman I'm gonna guess
she based on both her name and the way
and the fact that her email was
definitely an AOL email who was one of
our esteemed readers who I think is of
the older generation Phyllis Phyllis I
mean it's your name Phyllis you're
probably yeah one of our one of our
beloved one of our beloved VIPs
um and Phyllis is great she told me that
I absolutely need to shave my beard
because I said it on the show and I've
got two bearded gentlemen here do you
think I could pull it off it's just like
you had the beard oh my God five years
now so mine's I'm about five years or so
into the beard six years I could never
shave it it's I'm more beard than men
you're more wow I'm 21 years in on the
beard really I've had it since 02. you
keep it tight enough that you almost
look like someone that
I keep it super close like the old
school Wolf Blitzer like all remember
Wolf Blitzer you're always like what's
going on with the wolf Blitz I used to
do a joke about if you stare into his
beard long enough you start tripping
like your own mushrooms so so also by
the way I have I have a theory about
this that we talked about on the show
what is the Vodka think about the beard
I haven't heard from her in like 10
years
you should you should literally it's
actually be like I'm on set with Buck
Sexton who lives in Miami right there
you should text her and be like I'm here
in Miami with buck and he's just like
you know you don't call you don't write
you know I'm like I'm like chop lip I'm
like chopped liver over here you don't
do a guest appearance I'll tell her
where we're going her dad asked me to be
in his cabinet okay and she doesn't even
text I'm just saying yeah this is
getting weird it's getting weird did you
ever date anybody famous
I don't think so I didn't date her I did
it was no I did not date her that is see
this is how these things all get crazy
it was it was Junior Prom which is more
like School formal junior year promise
senior year so it's a different thing I
went to the same school as her no no no
she I invited her I invited her you know
we knew each other she was it was a date
but it wasn't you know we weren't like
going steady or anything you know I
don't want you know Jared to like hire
the massage to take me out of something
you know what I mean so I'm just you
know trying I don't think so it's her
banger
good heaven sir
okay no I'm I can feel it how could you
even bring we were friends
I think I got a high five at the end of
the night I can't believe you're putting
this on the internet like it's on the
internet I think that's a fabulous
question what happened to our glasses oh
we have actual glasses now we can shift
because we're all class here well um yes
I'm trying to think have you ever dated
anybody famous you don't have to name
them
uh I don't think so actually well I got
remember I got married when I was 25. so
the answer is 100 and the answer is 100
no because I was only 25 when I got
married nobody cared about me for you
know years so I never got to cash in on
the buck I'm a bachelor in New York City
for 25 years 28 some odd years in Europe
let me tell you I've always thought that
it'd be fun to start a podcast but it
would have to be very unfiltered I mean
it's funny because when we go on
podcasts like he's cursing and dropping
f-bombs but I'm so like yeah yeah in the
I I just I still can't even on Bill
Marshall you know I asked him I was like
I can really curse you actually and they
just started saying things but I just
can't do you guys find it's tough to get
out of radio mode because you've said
that to me a couple times where suddenly
you're talking to people and you realize
you're in like radio guy because there
is that little you guys are both the
same off camera but all of us have this
little there's a performance there's a
performance quality right yeah there's a
thing I think the biggest challenge with
radio and we've talked about this I I
genuinely don't believe there should be
any restrictions on what we say Clay's
not driving
um so yeah I'm the chauffeur by the way
do you know that our studio is out it's
like where they have the alligators and
the fan boats and stuff we're way yeah
it's always out yeah we can get from the
building we are in right now to where we
are going this evening without you
having to drive but my car is outside so
how am I what am I going to do I'm gonna
leave it here this also this is this
neighborhood I mean I live not far but
like you know it's a little spicy it's a
little spicy around here you know Dave
Rubin you got all this locals money I'm
just gonna throw this out there like I
don't want my lips you got you got Arm
Security here what are you saying now no
I mean I just I think it's a good
transition thank you I I have a long
thought that there should the idea of
there being still restrictions on what
can be said on radio yeah is very
Antiquated oh um yeah you know that so
like I we can't curse on our radio show
by and large there's like you know eight
words you can't say without it being
like a community standard FEC violation
that standard made sense in 1950 yeah I
think nowadays people are choosing every
they don't accidentally end up on our
radio show right right um and so I think
the audience is able to handle cursing a
little bit but I will say I got the
level of the regulation like to me even
on YouTube I really so here's my first
but every now and again
people know like like we both you notice
you hang out with us socially you know
we we curse in our private lives I don't
pretend to like wag a finger at people
about that but we do I mean we have like
we have 10 year olds that listen yeah
right and so that's where like the
people who are like oh like you said
like gosh darn and they get upset at us
that's I'm not really but if someone's
in the car and they got their
eight-year-old and their 12 year year
old and we like you know let an F-bomb
or something fly I I would you know what
I mean like that's where I think it's
what does radio have now it's a three
second delay still oh yeah we have like
20 something seconds oh yeah I don't
think am I wrong I don't think we've
ever said no we've never had to drop it
you've never been bleeped once oh I used
to when I did look when I did local
sports radio in Nashville it wasn't even
just me we would have callers come in
and just go off right like on which is
great radio yeah and you're supposed to
hit the dump buttons yeah and uh
sometimes you're like you forget or you
punch the wrong button or whatever so
back in the day when I did local Sports
Talk Radio I mean there were people like
we definitely violated some FCC rules
over like uh what could be said but I've
never as a solo host I don't believe I
have ever uh ever cursed uh live on the
radio so then does that seem weird to
you guys at this point so we can be
sitting here you obviously can say
whatever you want we have no delay it is
what it is now you have a 20 second
delay you're you're gonna slightly it's
not just about by the way what we do is
super weird right like so especially
radio my wife will sometimes come up
Buck now has a home studio I've got a
home studio there are people here
working on your show we can look at them
there's an audience of your talented
staff right he's doing nothing when I
sit in an empty in an empty studio in my
house yeah I talk as if there are people
watching my wife will come up and make
fun of me like you move your hands
so it is an abnormal thing to sit in
front of a microphone and talk for three
hours with no one actually able to tell
everybody to do this you have to be you
have to be kind of weird
together I'd say like a couple times a
quarter I mean rarely wow it's all
because
right now yeah well but it's not much
different right because we have the
FaceTime set up so I I'm looking at him
we can see both back and forth we stare
into each other's eyes for three hours a
day I talk to him more than we then I
talked to my wife or he talks to his
wife yeah she just realized even though
we're all going out tonight I know
you're dipping out for dinner with the
boss you're going out with the casa
dragones guy so so there's boss of the
whole Corporation yeah
I got to meet this guy not everyone's
Dave Rubin just calling all the shots
for himself you know what I mean some of
us someone's got to answer to yes the
chances I fire myself very slim that was
the benefit I mean you asked a question
earlier about and and I said this the
other day because we talked to a lot of
people in their 20s and 30s and they're
like hey how do you move into media and
I bet you would agree with this I I
would have been far more nervous being
100 honest if I didn't know now kick oh
yeah because I knew that ultimately I
controlled my own fate and even if
you're trying to be completely honest in
the back of your mind if somebody else
controls your job it's hard to say
exactly the only time I say what I look
if For Better or Worse correct it's all
coming out of my brain and it is what it
is the only place I've ever worked where
they tried to control what I've said in
any in any real way with CNN which is
unsurprised which doesn't by the way and
the way they would do it well you say
that right yeah no it shows how it's
shifted because it used to I mean people
were like you were saying I'm like yeah
I was there Kelly was there Dana lash
worked at CNN like you go down like
there's all these people who are right
wing who used to be CNN contributors and
would you know present a conservative
point of view in the Trump era it it
just the place changed I mean when I say
and I mean in 2016 it went from and even
like the producers like people were kind
of you were you were like like unclean
like you were a bad yeah if you came on
air to say good things so the funny
thing is they actually tried to extend
me but I've told clay it's because I
used to do a lot of counter-terrorism
analysis from them because of CIA CTC no
big deal and and so they would have me
do their their you know panels on
Terrors and stuff like that but I said I
wasn't gonna keep the I had no job and I
was like I'm not keeping this job I just
can't do this anymore that was 2015
2016. so my contract ended at the 20 at
the 2016 election I was done so when
Trump won it's like do you want to stay
here and see how this is and the answer
was no but even just the institutionally
the whole place got more and more
hostile and I mean I remember this like
I so I grew up because you know you you
were like a moderate and you were like a
communist who's come over tonight which
is which is exciting you know I'm still
you know what I mean yeah you know
welcome welcome to the team and I I grew
up and I was watching like Hannity and
combs you know I think definitely in
college I think in high school
um and I was always getting smacked
around yeah that was a good show though
I liked that show it was a good show and
actually he was but you know you used to
see and you know sight mediaite only
people people well ten years ago it was
fine it was perfectly fine and now it's
left left wing I know but it used to be
basically the best fights between
Talking Heads on TV so it was actually a
really fun site because it was like you
know people throw down where does that
even happen anymore what forum is there
Bill Marshall they've got you know
they've had you on neon yeah that's
crazy they won't have me on they will
they actually they will I have not been
on I've been on the podcast oh and they
have promised me many many times and
canceled me many times and I just don't
want it I think my point I would be like
I feel like I did what I had to do with
Bill and it would almost be ridiculous
to have me on actually I don't think
I've even said this on air but I went
there a couple weeks ago because I was
in LA for something else and I went to
the show and for years that for
literally 20 years I've been trying to
get on politically incorrect even before
that so I've been trying to sit down
with this guy forever I went I'm
backstage and I've been backstage many
times and met all the producers EPS blah
blah blah and was always telling me I
was trying to sell myself like let me on
yeah yeah bill doesn't get the left
what's really happening for the first
time ever I could not I swear to you I
don't mean this patting myself on the
back in any I was just like I don't give
a and all of The Producers were
coming up to me
back in the day I mean you were single I
think for a long time too but uh the
moment you don't care is when they all
they all start to care right the moment
you're like yeah like I don't know if
I'm gonna call you like whatever they're
just like what do you mean you know I
swear to you if they if if I got a text
as we were sitting here like you want to
do it this Friday I would view it in a
way as more of a headache than anything
else like like I don't feel like I have
anything to prove in that way anymore
and and that's part of such a machine
my point is just uh that there's really
no Forum left I mean think about it if
they were to take you know one of us
three of us whatever and and put us
there with some people who have you know
the thing is it has to be it's almost
like a boxing match you have to people
relatively equal weight right like I was
invited recently to buy somebody they're
like oh well you debate like some like
uh I don't know something like Tick Tock
influence or something it's a friend of
mine and I'm like no I'm not going to
invade some guy I've never heard of
before who has you know but there should
be a place where we can get back to
those 2010 era mediaite Thunderdome
Throwdown debates I mean I remember
Chris Hitchens yeah all right yeah you
know throwing the middle finger up to
the Bill Maher audience like this there
used to be this stuff and dude it's but
the truth is and I know this is easy for
us to say but this is a failure of the
left not of the right yeah we all would
have done it when I when I was still on
the left and my show was starting to
take off because I was complaining about
the left from the left I would have you
know Ben Shapiro on Harry Elder and
Prager and all these guys and I would
get hate only from the left why would
you even sit down with them yeah the
people on the right would be like Ruben
you seem like a bit of a nut bag like a
lefty nut bag but it's nice you treat
them with respect we went we were in DC
two weeks ago I interviewed I think 16
Republicans every person we reached out
to said yes and then three couldn't do
it Mitch McConnell fell so he couldn't
do it Rand Paul's assistant got stabbed
in PC so he couldn't do it and then
there was the the shooting in Tennessee
so Marcia Blackburn that's about we got
everybody else we reached out to I think
20 Democrats
no no responses from 19 Rashida Talib at
least said no so that tells you it right
there I'm not known as a hardcore I'm
people used to criticize you're supposed
to be you're supposed to be the gateway
drug you're supposed to be the one that
people can experiment with before they
take the full red pill and the truth is
I would treat them with the same recipe
yeah I write down with AOC I have said
crazy things about AOC I think she is a
communist and a larper and a blah blah
blah but I would treat her with the same
responsibility I mean you can it's
because people I used to get this
actually back in the CNN days you would
they'd say like why do you even go there
and by the way the answer after a while
was well now it's no longer worth me
going there but there was a time when
you would actually be able to get some
shots in like I I crushed Alan
dershowitz in a gun debate once because
he doesn't know anything about guns
brilliant constitutional law professor
doesn't know a damn thing about Firearms
right I mean you have these
opportunities I mean you know van Jones
and I debated BLM 1.0 like you had these
chances now the the host would cheat and
like you know step on you and not the
other person and all that sort of stuff
but I feel like like one of the reasons
why you know we're sitting here we're
just talking about how crazy they are
all the time now is that no one has to
defend their ideas anymore in any Forum
anywhere anytime it's all just you know
Amen Corner for the left and honestly a
lot of it on the right as well and and I
I think that I think that we're missing
something and I don't know how to no I
don't know how to bring it back I would
love to believe me Richard Dreyfuss on
the show this week we haven't aired it
yet but Richard Drive is so actor not
known for politics particularly but he
wrote a book about Civics and for an
hour that's all he talked to me about he
just wants to find a place that you can
have these debates and I was like listen
that's really what I set out to do and
what I would still do but we have one
side that simply will not do it the
thing is they're winning despite not
doing it yeah and they and the reason
when real time when you're wondering why
the guests are so shitty it's like he
knows if he puts good conservatives on
or good libertarian or whatever the hell
we all are if he puts any of us on we
will do it well do you remember when
Dennis tiger was on there like two years
ago and it was shocking that they put
him on at all and Dennis started talking
about transgender stuff and they're
mocking him and making fun of him and
everything Dennis said turned out to be
true but there's no there's no way
the marketplace of ideas doesn't exist
anymore
that's the biggest challenge right is
people speak entire because I think
about this all the time because in my
mind and I'm always trying to persuade
people who are persuadable like in my
mind I'm like for our show I want there
to be a massacre in 2024. oh because I
think it's worse than him yeah I think
the only way
Democrats get sane is if identity
politics and cancel culture yes get
obliterate the the other thing I mean I
think that's true one thing that I I
underestimated uh in all of this and
it's partly what I saw with covid and
also what you're seeing in some of these
cities is that because of the
ideological ossification right because
of of that hardening that's occurred
where no one's exposed these other ideas
what we would think would be corrective
pain
doesn't actually result in Chicago is a
perfect example this doesn't actually
result in because they're like no no
this is part of the process and you
start to see it's almost a Soviet early
Soviet Bolshevik level thinking of all
right like there's going to be famine
but on the other side of famine is going
to be the Utopia it basically proves
them right yeah because it proves that
the system doesn't work correct and and
so in places like San Francisco for
example your people say like well hold
on think people are fleeing there's
trash everywhere there's opener drug use
there's more overdoses than ever before
you all the metrics show it's getting
worse but they're just thinking well
this just show us how broken and racist
and oppressive the system actually is so
we need an even more radical solution
over the long term and double down on
this in the short term now I do think
that breaks at some point like they
start to lose more people I'm just
saying that their threshold for that
pain point is way more than I than I had
anticipated in New York Trump winning in
20 would have forced a realization and
reflection on the left then covet
happened and they managed to drag Biden
across the Finish Line I mean look just
think about it from and this I've got
this book coming out in in August
Democrats have won seven of the last
eight elections in the popular vote
the team that is dominating doesn't
change their tactics yeah right until
you get your ass kicked and that is what
we are waiting for and frankly the
entire 21st century the only election
everybody acknowledges is Obama won in
20 2008. and doesn't that feel like a
freaking lifetime ago talk about change
doesn't that seem like a it doesn't even
seem like this country and uh Obama
could never be the nominee with 2008 as
his campaign slogan now he was against
gay marriage correct
there's a lot of Obama 2008 that would
be a republican campaign now yeah you
know I can but the whole premise of his
campaign was Reagan 80. Buck knows I I
love this Reagan 80 and Clinton 92 which
is America's so amazing that I could be
the president it did used to be the case
that the like even the notion of flag
waving and you there have been articles
written in the New York Times about this
more recently how it has changed but you
know Democrats and I mean literally flag
waving right like not in the in the
figurative sense that flag waving was
something both sides did and it was who
represents America better who has a
better Vision
who loves the country more and now from
the left flag waving is scary unless
it's the trans flag or the UN flag or
the American flag this this was a thing
during covert you may have even seen
this the New York Times wrote about it
yeah people who see yeah in Long Island
people see like 200 too many American
flags like oh that's scary for me and
and it just goes to show the the
psychology of this and and how much it's
changed and the other part of it is it's
amazing to me to see how they will say
that our side has become the radical
side when all of all of the positions of
the Democrat Party that felt like they
were on the slippery slope 10 years ago
have just been rocketing down that slope
without question they haven't moderated
on anything and I got that a guy with my
bio could be fully welcomed by the
Republicans I am married to a dude I
have children I am pro-choice Rudy's
pro-choice nobody thinks he's not a
conservative right like it's just so
obvious to me that there is one side
that talks about tolerance and one side
that actually exists within time so you
mentioned by the way DeSantis Trump we
haven't even talked about it so did you
we were watching this is the chance we
were watching during the uh during the
show today you may have seen it yeah
like it actually was airing on
television this putting you know like I
saw this one the pudding ad have you
seen it like so yeah so I did see it I
wish we could throw through it right now
but I saw it's a trump super Pac put out
the stupidest like pandering low budget
so when do you think DeSantis
announces and when do we actually get
the beginning of a real fight because
what we talk about on our show is first
of all we don't think we're in a
position because the the legacy of Rush
and the audience that we are fortunate
to have uh on the radio show we don't
get involved in Republican party do you
know how do you know how early this is
important we do though we do when we
don't talk about it every day but I'm
not going to say like hey we don't
endorse a republican you know how early
in the 2016 uh Rush endorsed Donald
Trump really important people know this
is it was I would have thought it was
late actually never as in you waited
until Trump so it was a trick question
well done there by the way yeah Rush
never endorsed Trump he talked about
Trump supportive of trump but you know
gave a fair shake to talking about Ted
Cruz and Rubio and everybody else you
know assessing it and really approaching
it like we we do as you know balls and
strikes or you know the coach of the
team or whatever you want to say and
this this demand that people seem to
have in the media right now of some
other people to come in at this can I
can we see what the campaigns look like
before we're supposed to make sure
politics but by it's funny because your
ability to use Sports sort of metaphors
to explain politics is incredible but
also the more politics becomes like
sports the more dangerous it is it's
very nice he's very proud of me when I'm
like clay you know on this one we're
gonna have to drop back and punt because
we're going to want to get a two-point
conversion or something well I mean you
know what I mean he's like he's like
well done Padawan so wait I'll answer
your question yeah you know the
legislative session in Florida closes in
I think at the end of May and they have
to change something related to him we've
talked about this yeah so there's a
technical reason that he can announce at
this point
um I suppose I mean I genuinely mean
this I suppose it is possible at some
degree that maybe he has not fully made
the decision my that's not my gut
feeling my gut feeling until it's made
it's not made right like we all assume
but until it happens this is what we say
by the way about about and we don't mean
this and this is one of these things
like media matter is going to get this
one day but it's who cares I mean if you
don't have a Media Matters vertical
right exactly I used to lie about me and
that pissed me off now they just repeat
what I said yeah
but but everything that we're saying
about 2024 and then landscape American
politics Joe Biden's 80 years old we
talk about this when you're 80 years old
when you're 80 I'm saying this like I
remember you know spending time with I
had a grandfather in New York City that
I was I was pretty close to it's been a
common 80 and like 80 is 80. my 80 years
died at 81 and 84. so so point being
here you know if Joe Biden was truly
between now and the election by you know
natural causes Health just let's say the
income clearly incapacitated in some way
it changes everything right so all this
projections about the match-up and
everything else so this notion that
we're supposed to set in stone right now
what 2024 on our side even on the
Republican side is supposed to look like
to me it's just this is a process for a
reason that has to play out I mean what
you know what what are the foreign
policies what are the projections of the
top candidates I do think it's funny and
we got to be honest about this one it
does seem like all the Republicans
running so far other DeSantis obviously
isn't in the other ones they're running
for positions in a trump cabinet like
there's no actual interest we were
talking about that today I mean I like
Santa's is getting attacked more as the
second is a nice guy but but this is not
his as the first place he's not running
for president it's very obvious right so
there's a couple things here so first
off right so on the vivec thing I like
him I like him too I don't I don't first
podcast with him like but yes his the
attacks are going and like they're just
not it's too obvious it's too obvious
it's like dude like a little bit if your
goal is to be the president then you
have to beat the favorite yes and it
seems like every single person who is in
the race so far is all focused on attack
they're all trying to be in the two
speed DeSantis is the favorite that's
what I think at this point I think
actually the polls are not making any
sense I think I'm telling you I did a
gig in Green Bay Bay Wisconsin
University Wisconsin about two weeks ago
yep I polled the audience now obviously
they're there to see me so there's a
certain selling but I I pulled the
others I said how many of you was about
300 people how many of you voted for
Trump last time literally every single
person yeah raised their hand I said how
many of you would prefer DeSantis I
would say it was about 95 it was it was
there were maybe 10 people that didn't
raise their hand and then we talked
about why and basically everyone and I
did it fully as a as a backwards q a
like I really was questioning them and
letting them talk everybody was
basically like it's just enough this is
the best guy that we have now he's
younger there's no mean tweets it's
functional Florida's functioning this is
the best guy we can put out we thank
Trump like there was no anger towards
yeah and that's why the Trump guys
online the uh the the Trump influencer
types are doing him such a disservice by
being so it's funny because some of them
attack us on our show for not being like
pro-trump enough and we all voted for
Trump right yeah twice yeah I gladly
vote
but the thing for us that's funny is
that we have people that are also
complaining to us from the audience that
we're too pro-trump right here I just
like him okay the the sports analogy
that makes sense and this comes from
doing sports is when you talk about
Auburn or Alabama or Michigan Ohio
the other side always rips you because
it is such a passionate situation and
that's the reality now and what I just
keep coming back to is
the single biggest vulnerability of Joe
Biden by far is his age yeah and
whatever you can do to focus on Biden
being 82 in 2024.
I think that is the killer app the
killer the problem is you have to
doesn't you have to make an argument now
to the base that you can't really think
of who you know your dreamiest dream
candidate is right now you really if you
want to win and the one thing I will say
about Democrats that I really do have a
begrudging respect for is their sheer
ruthlessness that whatever works like
whatever Federal perfect example you
know they take a a stalin-esque approach
to winning here in America which is just
like however I'm going to stay in power
is what I'm going to do and if if you're
looking at it from the perspective of
Independence and persuadable voters
um that that notion of somebody who's
clearly visual you know it also gets
into what are these people going to make
their final determination on these
aren't people that are following
politics generally if you're an
independent and people might argue with
this but I think you're kind of you know
open to things and maybe you're gonna
just go with you know the last few weeks
before the election and like this guy
looks good like I'm gonna give him a
shot yeah and the Optics of it I think
are very clear with a then he'll be what
82 yeah versus a guy who is is clearly
in his prime and also has really put
points on the board and let's remember
Joe Biden the only points Joe Biden ever
put on the board are getting reelected
for 40 years to basically be a show for
the credit card companies in Delaware
like this guy is a joke who stood for
nothing his whole life so there was
nothing ever impressive about him it was
just the juxtaposition Obama himself
said if you're right true right people
always forget like why wasn't Biden the
candidate in 2016 after eight years as
the VP because even the Democrats in
this guy was a schmuck yeah yeah thank
you just saying
did you want credit for me from that
schmuck I'm saying you know that sounds
like no it's close to a curse is what
I'm saying yeah I'm saying I'm letting
it rip a little bit here I said schmuck
look I would put it this way the
simplest way to do it is that what is
desantis's biggest let's assume DeSantis
is not a globalist rhino right so that's
what the Trump people are throwing at
him he's a sore like it's just not
that's just not gonna work it's just
nonsense and it doesn't work so let's
just put that aside for a second what
would his biggest downside be this is
what I asked Patrick David pbd and Rudy
there Rudy actually didn't have much as
much as he's a trump guy he really
didn't he's his thing kept being Trump
did it once and he can do it again yeah
so I let's just put that somewhere yeah
he's forgetting the second time pbd his
big and he likes to sandus a lot his
biggest one was that the book didn't do
as well as he thought but it was number
one on New York Times basically saying
it he has still has a PR issue
but the point is what what's the week
what's the weakness yeah so I think the
weakness is purely uh aesthetic and
subjective versus policy I don't think
it's policy based I think it's not
possible to hit him on policy I think
the way you could go after him is that
he's Scott Walker meaning great at that
time I'm not by the way I'm not saying I
agree with this but I'm saying the way
you could sort of attack DeSantis and I
think not have it be when they say he's
not good on covid I mean the two of us
you know you were living the free state
of Tennessee right you know the two of
us are sitting here going we literally
moved here we uprooted Our Lives because
he was so good on covid because we saw
what was happening here so that's just
it's actually insulting it's insulting
the intelligence of trump voters when he
says DeSantis was bad on coven because
that's just crazy talk okay but Scott
Walker was a really solid Governor
popular at the time obviously purple
stay difficult good with the teachers
union stuff dealing with this and then
he ran for president and just for
whatever reason on the national stage it
just sort of went like it just sort of
collapsed of its own weight and didn't
have that National level Sizzle do I
think that's likely to happen with the
santis no but do I think it's fair to
say say that maybe he's not yet ready
for that big stage and the theatrics of
it and the retail politics and
everything else fine on the policy
ground I have no answer in some way that
actually makes me more for him the idea
that maybe he isn't the most perfected
and I don't I actually don't take this
argument but like to just kind of give
the devil his due that he maybe isn't
Trump is better on TV sure like do I
think if it was now Trump and DeSantis
on the debate stage at the end they get
rid of everybody else is Trump a better
debater will Trump have more zingers I
mean I was at the debate that DeSantis
did with Charlie Christ he's not the
best debater yeah there was a moment
actually where Charlie Crist says to him
you won't even commit to to not running
for president will you DeSantis and
DeSantis won't answer now the reason he
wouldn't answer was because they had
agreed in writing beforehand you will
not question the other candidate so
DeSantis was trying to be honest he was
trying to abide by the rules that they
set
now Trump would have never abided by the
rules right and Trump would have turned
back at him and had a great Zinger and
and Charlie Chris was horrible at every
level but the point is he that may not
be his strength and and if at the end if
we're just looking for a television star
I know that's not what you're asking for
but at the end if that's really just
what we want
then we will get we will get Trump again
as the nominee but he will not be
president my my fear if I were assessing
DeSantis would be a couple of things one
he can be too scripted and that kind of
ties in with you okay with your analysis
and he doesn't seem normal and if I were
uh what do you mean by that I I mean
like he is very good at getting his
points and delivering them but he
doesn't seem really comfortable he's not
guy at the bar average
find it I'm not I'm just saying if the
what is Trump best at I think Trump gets
almost no credit for being able he's a
billionaire he can walk into a
McDonald's yeah in middle of nowhere
America and be totally normal totally
he's a queen connect and connect with
people I kept saying for years I kept
saying how is it that this orange man
billionaire with this crazy hair is more
authentic than every single Democrat and
the truth is like think about it who's
more authentic Donald Trump or Elizabeth
Warren who's more authentic no doubt
Donald Trump or Joe Biden or people he's
more authentic because he's more
authentic and I think right because he's
incredibly comfortable in his own skin
and I think that translates and so uh I
also think that um if I were if I were
like sketching out the Trump the the
truck so let me tell you also the
DeSantis attack the DeSantis attack
should be you lost to Joe Biden and you
will lose to him again and Biden is the
worst president in any of our lives like
that is the appeal right he may he may
turn off some Trump voters with that
because they're a trump voters yeah I
actually figured it should be something
else I think it should be look what I
set out to do in Florida look what I've
done look at the 1200 people that move
here a day a million in three years
nobody's leaving highest ever I get I
have a guest house by the way because
real estate here very expensive
I got a gym that you could maybe thank
you I I think it's going to get nasty
and that pudding ad that we were talking
about when we started is so ridiculous
that I think that both of these guys are
going to get rolling around down in the
muck and my biggest
I don't think they'll do it either and
I'll tell you this you can't Trump that
way I think yeah he's not going to do it
because that's playing but I'll also say
I think that when they go dirty on
DeSantis and they've done there's been
some dirty stuff I don't mean the
globalist rhino stuff is laughable the
groomer stuff is pretty aggressive like
that like that's that's dirty like
that's not that has no place I'm not
hitting I keep saying Trump make make
the case for Trump trump yeah
be above DeSantis and say like this one
I'm the leader I'm I'm not even going to
Feud with any other Republican now
especially he had an opportunity after
he got indicted to just come out and say
it's me versus Biden I'm not going to
say a single negative word against
anybody else
so who's the real that's what I'm
telling you I think the polls
something's wrong with the polls there's
only one guy being attacked right now by
MSNBC and by Trump and it's descended
can I put something out on Trump this is
the only time I can think of where Trump
and Trump people all of a sudden
entirely believe polls which is
interesting isn't it oh that's the polls
always where the polls lie whenever the
polls are negative the polls lie right
now vis-a-vis DeSantis we're told guys
it's all over before it even started
really because it's just based on polls
against a candidate who's not even a
candidate yet not officially announced
and you know that's interesting let me
ask you guys something else on this and
then they are they're giving us the
signal and then you guys
can we mooch off your YouTube following
though and tell people you have a clan
button for a radio show
we're on the interwebs and we would like
the smart Dave Rubin people to subscribe
to ours over there God it's like my
first day on TV subscribe to Clay Travis
and Buck Sexton show on YouTube please
we do fun things over there and we'll
have Dave back on now too so yeah does
he get paid more for today he's doing a
great job usually uh you know like I
have to be Shameless and promoted I
think he's learned something I love
shamelessness
play is a world-class promoter and I
love that we'll even be like be like oh
man like this story out of Salt Lake
City Salt Lake City another one of the
15 uh number one number one city we just
want to say thank you to everybody in
Salt Lake City for making us number one
of all radio shows in the nation and
that goes right in the story he does it
he's like the Terminator it's like the
program when you run your own media
business
you you have to be so Shameless to make
people aware that you exist you have to
you got to do what you got to do because
otherwise nobody will know and so now we
have a big you know we're in 500
stations or whatever and I can't turn
off the hey let me promote we have a PR
guy now at out kick yeah and like I'm
totally Blown Away by the fact that we
have a guy whose full-time job is to try
to get attention because when you're
starting literally at zero you've got to
do everything you can to make people
aware that you exist so he's picked up
on like the shamelessness that requires
I gotta just go how do you feel about
that I mean spiritually you know
um as as long as we add to those
stations we have I'm good with it man
whatever we got to do to get it I was
just reminded of something that when
clay has a couple of drinks he does the
slow blink you do the slope oh really it
starts to slow down a little bit Yeah I
do the slow bling too but I can tell
you'll be able to drive because you're
yeah no I'm ready I'm actually going to
get a haircut and I'm thinking about
having him do a straight A straight
shave right now oh wow foreign
have dinner with the with the big boss
man over there and then the whole
Florida crew is having dinner Florida
squad's getting it now they're going to
be pictures taken and then the the crazy
people of the internet are going to take
these pictures and they're going to say
that we're coordinating things we're
working against certain people working
for people Yeah we actually were just
hanging out but we should put hashtag
Illuminati hashtag Bilderberg
uh DeSantis secret Squad well again this
is this is uh this is the world that
exists now because 2022 everybody's on
the same team didn't go the way we
wanted yeah right let's be fair for most
races that were close 2023 is the
Alabama Auburn Michigan Ohio State you
know Yankees Red Sox and then 2024
everybody will come back together and
sing Kumbaya and unless Trump decides to
run as an independent uh then everything
would fall apart but um look I mean I
think it's going to get really nasty
throughout much of 23. and I don't think
there's anything wrong but you guys are
like I don't think you should roll out I
don't think there's anything wrong with
things getting nasty because I think
ultimately what it does is Biden's not
running against anybody right he's
already an awful candidate if they allow
him to be on the stage with whoever
emerges from the Republican party I hate
to tell you he could well he could drop
dead or they could just kick him out I
mean they're doing something with Gavin
clearly they are doing that he's waiting
in the wings I think for emergencies
but I don't even know technically how
you do it but it is clear that that
thing is in motion where if Biden goes
down or literally cannot speak or
whatever it is they're going to figure
out you know what we were talking today
I think that they will especially if
Trump is a nominee I think that they
will say that they can't platform Trump
and that's the way they'll avoid Biden
having to debate him
and the other question that I have that
that's out there floating around is
um to what extent as you know this Biden
Ridiculousness continues to roll to what
extent might they behind the scenes
start spending money to help Trump and
attack the scientists like they did in
22 with you know they claim that Trump
is this existential threat but then
everybody who supported Trump they
helped to vote so this is MSNBC one the
guy that will get them views that cannot
win or the guy that will ignore them and
win right
that really is what this all boils down
to there's a otherwise they all said for
four years how many people do you know
that said drunk you know it's like I
like the policies and things are working
but I don't like the Mean Tweets and the
attitude congratulations you got
DeSantis I think he's 45 years old or 46
years old three young kids a good father
a good a good is everything the
conservative movement says and has said
for the 41 years of my life they want
that is where we are just putting that
out there
I've enjoyed drinking tequila with you
fine Phil this is actually pretty good
by the way
have you ever seen this bottle before
and I just went to the store on the way
here this was who was it uh Kevin Hart
this is Kevin Hart oh that's cool good
for him I wish he had been able to host
the Oscars because he made a joke you
know 15 years ago people were upset
about it no no he should be banned from
humans oh yeah and guys
you guys love the camera I'm actually
gonna drink then so goodbye to you fine
people and I'm sorry now what's the show
and what are your names
your clay Travis Buck Sexton show we're
on YouTube as well we're on Rumble
basically if the platform exists you
should be able to find us somewhere in
that vicinity and they'll be somewhere
in Miami Beach this evening that's right
this shirt's not going to be able to
hide medication
please
foreign